Hello, everybody.
Give me a sec.
I'm waiting for the caffeine to kick in.
I know.
I told you guys.
And I told myself.
I will not take a nap before my stream.
But my body is so weak.
And the flesh, it needed the nap.
I think the worst part was that I took a nap at 12 p.m.
And then I fucking, I was out for four hours.
I was out for four hours.
And if it wasn't for the alarm, I would have kept on
sleeping.
Oh my god, this fucking skin suit as a tum- Also, also,
guys, okay, guys, I know this seems very weird that I'm
playing this game.
But I can explain.
This is- this is PG, family-friendly.
This is PG YouTube.
please also i need to make sure i don't swear for the first
10 minutes because like i i told you guys i got fucking hit
on the vade stream i got hit again and i have to send an
appeal and it's okay now it's monetized again but like i
guys i can't i can't keep having my vods get hit for
profanity i can't when did i swear it's over i already swore
I don't even remember guys I don't even remember swearing my
brain is not on at the moment anyway chat look I can explain
why I picked this game to stream this week I can explain
guys look I am but a cogwheel in the master plan content
creation and it is not my fault that bunny garden is now a
flavor of the month game it is not my fault i am merely just
following the masses i am but a sheep for the algorithm
i swear bunny garden is the bunny garden meta right now i
swear to god and youtube please do not demonetize me youtube
i just want to go to this family friendly restaurant this
this friendly establishment and see some ladies some women
who are very family friendly it is pg for pretty gals
pg for pretty gals that's what it means guys how is this
game the i don't don't ask me how this game is meta as the
fucking countless streamers are playing this game don't ask
me say hi thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
It may be friendly, family friendly, but friendly fire is
always on.
It's over.
YouTube, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Enough cope.
Okay.
Sir.
This is a nice establishment, guys.
Guys.
This is a nice restaurant.
It's a small business chat that we're supporting.
our local small businesses everybody so get your money ready
because these girls are gonna scam us
was that me am I height though what am I doing why did I
make such a big mistake I would exactly height though I
would never do something like this normally exactly my
company Oh my god, this is too real.
Okay, my company fired me.
It is what it is.
It's not the first time it's happened.
I'm thankful they hired me in the first place.
Oh god, why am I...
It's just too real.
I'm thankful they hired me in the first place.
I have nothing but gratitude for the company.
My boss even cried for me when they fired me.
He said, I'm sorry I couldn't help you out.
told me that this company wasn't the right fit for me and
that there are other places where I could shine it was nice
for them to say that okay is there really somewhere out
there someplace that would take in a fool like me maybe all
I needed to do was find my host club all along even if I
could get another job somewhere else I would just mess
everything up for the people there huh maybe my life is done
for i didn't even think it had started oh my god this is all
i needed to do find a nice local small business time to
drink my problems away i'm pretty sure there's a bar
somewhere in this building stare i'm sorry
Okay, should I read what she's telling you guys?
Or are you going to pretend you know Japanese?
Unless you do know Japanese.
Okay, I'll read it out loud for you guys.
Just throwing out a guess here.
But does something bad happen to you?
Sorry, pretend that you can listen to Japanese.
That's why you're trying to drink and forget everything?
Or...
me to go to your hostess club?
Okay, I'm bringing the volume up.
Okay.
Let me bring the volume up, guys.
Sound guy wants to hear this anime girl talk to him.
You're wrong.
What just happened to catch my eyes before I get to work?
Don't call us out like that.
You look so tired as of your life is over.
Oh my god.
Guys!
Thank god there's no eye trackers.
Guys, I hope your eyes are up here or here because you need
to read what she's saying.
I hope it's up here or here, guys.
Not anywhere else.
You look so tired as if your life is over.
You might be right, Miss Anime Girl.
I knew it.
Yata.
Oh, sorry.
This isn't something to be happy about.
Oh, am I going to get taken advantage?
My financial worry is going to get worse.
I should have hit it right on the bullseye.
It's so sad to think your life is over.
Yeah, I know.
Someone's like, please take advantage of me.
Fuck it.
What should I do?
then I'll really become a tote.
But I can't leave someone so hurt out in the cold.
Oh, woe is me.
Debbie Mercy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
My eyes are obviously in the middle so I can do...
What?
What do you mean?
Oh, don't worry.
I brought the volume up again.
Just for you sound guy.
Got it.
You don't have to come in the shop.
You can just have a sneak peek.
Oh, that's how they get you.
That's how they get you.
The sneak peek.
I don't know what's going on.
Oh, shit.
Really?
You do?
You work here?
Oh, I didn't know they opened this kind of bar there.
It's someplace where I can drink with girls.
I've never been in a shop like this before.
it's it's clean oh my god my life is a mess it's clean and
the girls are cute i guess i guess i'll give it a try you're
gonna get me in trouble sir no are you taking that money out
no sir don't take the money out oh my god we only accept a
hundred dollar bill sir and clearly you don't seem like
you're wise.
It's not, it clearly seems it's not wise to spend that type
of money.
So I can't come in.
That's all today.
I'll just give you a glimpse.
You come inside and I'm really a, oh no.
No.
Why did you let me see this?
If you're, if I give you the right to come to the shop as a
customer.
Whenever you're interested, I'll be waiting for you to come.
Mr. Toot, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Why waste your money on host clubs when you send it to
VTubers?
They're clearly superior.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
You send it to VTubers who are going to host this clubs so
you can get both the two experience at once.
You know?
You can live vicariously through the playing this game you
get both the vtuber and the hostess club let's see so you're
so sincere your life isn't over you'll be okay i know you
will huh
right now even if it was small i know you smiled that means
you're not you're not done yet what thank you I'll be here
at the shop waiting for you I'm looking forward to the next
time we can see each other oh you mean right now right all
right I'll let you go what was her deal she was so strange
she doesn't even know me but i guess i do feel a little
better i'm such a simple guy i see girls my my
my self-esteem guys is help happy self-esteem
Just a simple little guy.
Now, I don't know if I really want to get drunk and forget
about everything.
I'm just gonna go home.
My self-esteem is up now.
My life isn't over, huh?
No way.
Why would I take something a girl said to me seriously?
When I don't even know her name?
She didn't seem to be joking around, but, you know, I mean,
it's not like anyone has ever told me that my life is done.
I'm the only one who thinks that.
If I don't finish it myself, maybe it's still possible to
start again.
Oh my gosh, that gorillas, but what if they're anime girls?
Princess two.
I'm sorry for calling you.
I'm sorry for calling you about notice.
You know how you were saying work was busy and you need to
help?
Did you still need help?
If you like, would you take me?
Am I going back already?
Oh my god, it's like persona.
Wait, oh my god, a lot of days passed.
It's been a week since I...
Oh, I got a new job!
I thought I called the hostess club again.
I...
I was like, please take me.
It's been a week since I started my new job.
What should I use my money on?
That being said, me being positive is all thanks to her.
Let me spend all the money I've earned just to reward her.
Should I go to that chick's shop?
This week's salary has been paid.
Payment is made every Saturday for your new job.
Spend it carefully.
if I okay this week's salary has been paid at 45,000 yen oh
my god what wait there's warranted this I'm gonna have to
gamble wait what oh my god oh this is so fucked up
oh no this is how they're gonna get you the gambling this is
how they're gonna get you we're gonna go pachinko soon okay
i think there was a shop here i'm a bit nervous though
oh my god that's her the customer who looked tired you came
that's right the customer who looked tired i'm here and i
have My life is so much better and it is here, but you know
what?
I felt like I've had it too good for too long.
So I want to feel like what it's like to be broke again, but
also have female attention.
Hello, thank you, my super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What kind of job does this guy have to afford a hostess bar
gambling and vacations?
Thank you, but my super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Joshua, thank you, my super chat.
your entire paycheck look i can't if i gamble away my entire
paycheck how would i spend my money on pretty women is this
your first time at a place like this yes for the mystery
meta that's right i've never been here before i see well
then i'll give you a brief explanation about how it works
Oh, that skirt is way too short.
Thank God my head is covering the other women.
Please, I don't know anything, so this will help.
The name of this shop is Bunny Garden, a fun place to drink.
That's all.
Oh, it seems like I should understand, but I don't.
Shady, thank you for the Akka soup.
Holy moly.
Wow.
It's red.
Just like the color of her bowtie.
Right, guys?
Well, you gradually get used to it, so it's okay.
I'll be really happy with King you a lot of lots of times.
I agree.
To do that, I have to work hard at my current job.
Well then.
Oh no, why are you looking at me like that?
The moment she put her hands up, my eyes went to the face.
Well then, I want you to be able to do your best.
So I hope I can give you lots of healing.
That makes sense.
I feel like I can work harder if I feel better.
It's the saddest.
I'm sorry.
I didn't hear your order.
Did I order something?
I'm sorry.
My mind is somewhere else right now.
Here you are.
This is the menu.
Maybe I'll have a drink.
What drink did you want?
A customer must purchase a drink.
A price your drink can increase your...
Did you hear that?
She said if I buy the most expensive drink, I'll be so
likable Okay, maybe not that expensive All right, I'll give
them a little sneak peek of my money All right, this
sparkling wine has gorgeous aroma of grape.
It's popular worldwide Especially oh my god the women like
it.
Maybe they'll share the drink with me My show.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you seeing how much they have to carry i think those
girls need the money to deal with bad problems thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you all right i want to
confirm my order oh my god see this is how you do it guys
guys and women this is how you do it you buy a drink that
women like so they'll want to drink it with you not because
they're trying to make me order two not because that she
wants me for my money.
It's because she's really thirsty, guys.
You don't understand.
She's just really thirsty, and I order... Oh, shit.
Anyway, it's because she's really thirsty and she saw me
order a drink that she likes because this drink is something
that women likes.
That's why.
Joshua, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
women will come your high roller dokey women are temperate
the slot machines are eternal thank you for the akasupa
thank you thank you you can treat the cast members to a
drink some drinks are more preferred than others and some
are easier to get drunk on you don't treat who the fuck is
she give me the other girl
you never forget your first guys your first hostess if you
don't treat them to drinks they will prioritize oh no i'm
the only customer you should worry about i'm the only
customer you should talk to treat your cast member toy drink
oh my god i have to buy another one oh oh my god i should
buy a cheap one for myself because because i don't deserve
it and she's the queen all right here here's also the rustic
of course of course you deserve it girl you fuck oh my god
guys are you looking at her head right now you can talk to
the cast something might happen you can give a gift to each
cast member once a day gifts can be purchased from home you
can treat the cast members to food there may be a preference
for different foods.
Guys, women like it when you listen to them.
I'm getting Kana nervous.
Pro tip.
Pro tip right here.
I mean, it's going to be the first time I meet this next
customer.
My heart feels like it's going to explode from how fast it's
next customer?
What do you mean next customer, Kana?
I literally just got here and you're gonna leave me already
oh what am i saying the purpose of this place is to make
customers feel relaxed not stressed if i'm in a state like
this i'm sure the customer's gonna feel the same come on now
you got this this is guys guys guys to avoid this you have
to customer guys this is it kaitu they give it a super chat
thank you thank you ayo remove the tutorial explanation okay
let's start out with the usual we're right here this is
where my cursor is right now to her face her big personality
lies in the face guys lies in the face the first step in
order to become friends you're the customer so please go
ahead with everything you've got.
The first step.
Like an introduction?
So a toast or something.
What about...
Oh no.
I need to be likable now.
Proceed and enjoy the conversation by selecting your
preferred answer.
There's some things that affect likability.
Choose your words carefully.
It's okay, guys.
I'm a woman.
I know what we like to hear.
It'll be so fucked if I get this wrong.
Guys, I'm on home turf now.
Guys, I'm on home turf.
I know what we like, I think.
The first step?
Okay.
Like an introduction.
Like an introduction?
You can do it, Doki.
Yes, I do it!
Okay, bro, bingo!
We met for the first time after all, so it's only natural to
start with introductions.
Anyway, I'd love to know more about you.
I gotta lie.
Because women don't want to know the truth.
Right.
My name is Haito Kanda.
Hmm, Haito Koon.
Haito Koon.
Yeah, Haito Koon.
it joshua thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
trying to cook you even before the next customer comes in
speed running the gambler route thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you you don't need to keep looking at me
like guys i can't i can't help that my cursor keeps falling
down there okay guys it's just natural it's fps games
because in fps games you always have to aim in the center
okay guys so my my mouse is naturally in the center it's not
my fault that she's in the center guys okay it's just it's
just reflexes okay my mouth you know like it has to fall in
the center naturally when i play fps games you don't need to
keep looking at me like
I wanted to remember your name and face, you see.
So I was doing my best to store that into my head.
But there's no need to worry.
I matched your face to your name now.
It is, I swear, Yoshi.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Super sure.
Joki Gamer Reflex.
It is.
I naturally have my mouse in the center.
Okay, it's my turn now.
My name is Kana.
I don't mind if you give me a nickname, but I sure hope you
remember me.
Of course I'll remember you, Kana.
You never forget your first, guys.
You never forget.
All right, I'll do my best to match your name to your face
then.
Kana-chan.
Yeah.
Kana- Kana-chan.
Hmm.
Hey, stop it.
You're making me all flustered.
I didn't know it felt this embarrassing to be stared at.
Oh, really?
Okay.
She's good.
She knows what's going to get me to open my wallet.
She's so fucking good, guys.
If I do that, I'll be like, Oh, stop it, dragons.
Oh, you're making me all flustered.
Oh, my gosh.
I didn't know it felt this embarrassing.
Let me stare at dragons.
Stop.
I suppose.
I suppose there are some things you need to learn from
first-hand experience.
Yeah, I guess I got a little smarter from this whole
situation.
Dimitri, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Lock in, Doki.
This cute fictional girl game is less intimidating.
If you take it way too seriously and just power it through.
I am taking this so seriously, guys.
You don't understand.
I literally spent 20,000 yen already.
That is very serious.
Tell me more about yourself, Haito-kun.
I messed up real bad at work recently.
And because of that, the boss fired me.
So I've been assisting a friend at his work ever since.
Oh, that sounds rough.
Daichobu, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank
you.
And Zip's wallet.
If I was in your shoes, I probably wouldn't even be able to
eat.
Though I'm sure words can express just how awful you must
feel.
Oh, I feel so awful, Kana.
I might need some affection right now.
All right, I've got it.
i'm gonna do my absolute best in order for you to get back
on your feet oh my gosh she's gonna give me personal
attention the time you spend here will be of a constant
smile i can assure you that much oh don't worry kana this is
my own this is my own personal uh feeling and want she did
not influence me at all guys but because of what she said i
must come to the hostess club every day now like out of my
own responsibility out of my own personal what i will spend
every day with her not because of anything she said i hope
we get along haito kune haito kune more
drinks i want to keep talking to you more oh god me only me
oh of course i would love to extend kana um but because the
boss oh i know you can't do anything about it kana the boss
is required it's regulations i know and i don't want to get
you fired kana i would absolutely pay more to extend my time
with you thank you i thought you're going home already Oh,
Kana, did you, do you like the rustic?
Oh, wait, I'll order something cheap.
I'm going to let the, ooh, okay, I'm going to get beer.
I like how beer is in such a, like, fancy, fancy glass cup.
What was it called?
Glassware.
I was like, is this still a cup?
I swear, I swear there's, like, a different name for this.
But it's so fancy for beer.
All right, we'll get orange juice.
I hope there's alcohol in.
here from a cassie's liquor and specialty orange juice low
alcohol percentage is popular among women okay i'm gonna
grab this um yeah champagne glass can i have some too oh
don't worry you deserve the very best my queen you get the
rustic how much money do i have left 30 000 okay i don't
need to eat
Don't need to eat for the, I just go to the convening every
day for food.
It's okay, guys.
I just need to, I just need to go to the convening.
I can just eat at the convening every other day until my
paycheck, guys.
It's okay.
Really?
Thank you.
I'll get you a bottle.
James, Japanese salary, man, bankruptcy simulator.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Should we eat together?
Ghana?
Oh my god.
Let's grab something nice.
We can share.
We can share Parfait together.
Kana.
Yeah.
It tastes amazing.
I love this.
Oh, you want to?
You want some too?
Stare.
You're staring again.
Stream extension.
Adrian, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
If you think about it, it's...
Okay, this is fun.
Okay, I'm gonna say something that's, like, a bit fucked up.
But, like, the stream extension thing sort of reminds me of
Sub-A-Thon.
It's sort of like, it's Sub-A-Thon.
Because you're sub-ing to extend the stream.
I'm sorry.
Maybe I have a bad habit of staring at things like that and
trick.
I trick her, guys.
Don't tell me.
I have bed hair or something.
No, it's nothing like that.
I thought this when I first saw you, Haito-Kun.
But you seem like a really kind...
Only me, right?
This is the first time you told this to anybody, right,
Kana?
Really?
I don't know if I am.
Do you want more of my money?
It's only been a little bit since we first met.
So I don't know for sure, but I'm just talking about first
impression.
Oh my god!
I knew it was naturally kind-hearted.
I knew it.
I do have a feeling you're really kind.
My first impressions tend to be accurate, you know?
I knew.
I bet you I'm the first person to see you said this too.
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
Your eyes, especially...
They seem so gentle.
Stare.
...
Hey, it's no fair for you to stare back.
I'm gonna get all flustered Can you keep drinking Haiko-Kun?
Don't don't push yourself.
Okay, X thank you for the 50 gifted chips.
Thank you.
Oh my god And just like that X has extended my time with you
guys Remember to thank and Thank you for the gifted chips
Would you like to?
Oh, of course Of course, because my dragoons extended my
time with them, so I will extend my time with you, Kana.
Yay, you're gonna stay a bit longer!
What drink did you want?
Oh, um, I don't know how much money I spent.
Don't worry, I'll drink the Ulan highball.
Especially selected sochu mixed with Ulan teeny.
It's a very easy drink and has a rich flavor and lovely
scent.
Oh, don't worry, don't worry.
Okay, I'm a little sort of, um, I'm a little sort of broke
right now.
So I hope it's okay that I go 5,000 yen cheaper.
You can change girls.
No, I refuse.
I refuse to change girls.
She is my new Oshi because she showed me just a little bit
of attention and kindness.
And now I'm hers forever.
Toki Kana extension fun.
Katnip, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yep, yep.
It tastes great.
Oh, yes.
Whoa, look up here, guys.
Wait, I can actually move it.
Mike, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
attention joshua thank you magenta soup thank you thank you
do you think they are faker how dare you those are not that
is a natural hair color joshua how dare you this is all
natural hair color because that is exactly what you're
trying to ask for right let's get to know more about her
Oh.
Did you hear that?
You heard that, didn't you?
Be honest with me.
You heard that, right?
We heard what?
That sounded like it came from your stomach.
Oh, so you did hear that.
I'm hungry, okay?
You can't blame me.
Oh my gosh, are they not feeding you here?
Oh, guys, I'm also so hungry.
What should I eat when I get home?
I wonder.
Are you planning on buying something on your way home?
Are you going to cook?
What do you think?
Why don't we make this a little quiz?
How hungry.
Do I tend to cook more, or am I the type to resort to buying
pre-made stuff, or do I go out to eat a lot?
Oh, God.
Okay, this is a bit difficult.
My little hint to you is I love eating rice in particular.
I could probably just eat white rice for an entire meal.
Oh, God.
Okay, wait.
I'm a woman.
I know this.
I feel like that isn't really much of a hint.
you're right but come on answer my question okay i think i
should say cook often because like if i say buy pre-made
food a lot should just be like what you think i can't cook
for myself so like i'm gonna say cook often good i knew it
i'm a woman kind of good work
way to do it right thinking as much as you want at home oh
what they were all correct i was just never was gonna okay
okay don't take this away from me kana to be honest all of
those options are correct so depending on our mood i'll cook
buy food or eat out what's the point of this quiz no no of
course not it was not boring i mean there's no incorrect
answers i can't think of a kind of quiz to give you so right
kana thank you so much kana for giving me such a generous
quiz when you say it like that i guess it was pretty fun
joshua thank you for the magenta soup but thank you thank
you everything in this establishment is a scam the balance
the drinks you just drink a flashing flaming moe in the
slots can't win but i got but i got personal attention
that's enough of a win for me joshua she is here to make me
smile i got you to smile haito i guess my job here is done
then no no it's not done it's already this late no haito
don't I spent so much money, Haito!
No!
Oh my god!
How much is that in US, guys?
How much is that in US?
God, please!
Oh wait, that's just the cover track, sending it three
times.
Oh, I bought three rustics.
It's okay.
It was worth it for her happiness.
If you can please the cast members in the shop, they will...
$320?
For kanas.
For kano.
If you can please the cast members in the shop, they will
see you out in a good...
Look, they're so happy.
Haito Yosenov is more motivated to work.
work and earn a higher salary for one week see guys this is
a good thing i am make like now i will earn more money for
my for for height though oh wait no for me for kana i will
earn more money for kana high motivation for work can lead
to a raise and an increase in base salary so what she is
doing is not is is not wrong it is morally right because
it's making me richer thank you for today yeah thanks for
everything see you soon i'll be back tomorrow it was such a
nice place and this customer service was great maybe i'll go
there for the time being honestly i thought it was pretty
all right guys okay i have 10 000 yen and like i feel like i
can gift a member a vacation like with me right like oh my
god okay all right let us let us go gambling you can try
gambling of course sometimes you win and sometimes you lose
keep your fingers crossed they're taking on the challenge
all right we need to make money for kana um epsilon thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you ito is a show
don't say that but my girl just because she's giving me
attention and not you does not mean she's filled with lies
you don't understand you never got haito's attention oh shit
that's it oh my god i gotta like they all say in gambling
when you when you're already winning you gotta keep going
That's what they all say Kana extension FeeFan Justine,
thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank you Okay, but
what if I can double it?
That's what they all say Never quit while you're ahead Wait,
I'm Haito, sorry Sorry, Kana Like messed up my brain a
little bit I can't tell if I'm Kana I don't know how you
tell anymore.
I can't tell.
Okay.
There you go.
Everyone quits right before they hit it big.
Exactly.
And that is why you're right.
Look at that.
Everyone quits before they hit it big.
Come on.
Give me that money.
No!
Okay.
But like, you can't end on a loss.
You can't end on the loss guys Gambling gambling it's white
that means good what guys you can't end on the loss It's
okay.
I have convenies
Oh gosh, but yeah, oh my god 30 okay now I should stop
though Zekra thank you for the magenta soup, but thank you.
Thank you.
Here's take my birthday money for gambling my birthday was
on the 20th so can't please get a belated birthday wish
thank you for the magenta zoopah zekra thank you thank you
happy birthday to you happy birthday to you happy birthday
dear okay um oh sorry we ran out of time zekra uh but my
boss said that like i'm joking happy birthday dear zekra
happy birthday to you yay um all right we gotta buy gift for
for kana you can purchase gifts to give to the cast on rare
occasion the lineup may change guys what do you think kana
would like oh my god do you think oh i think she'll love a
plush toy oh she seems like a girl that that likes plushies
oh my god the luxury okay not gonna lie she'll definitely
like a luxury it's bad i shouldn't buy makeup because then
i'll be like she'll be like what you think i need makeup i
shouldn't buy flowers because flowers will eventually die I
think I'm going to spend all my money on a plush toy.
There we go.
I won this by gambling.
It's okay, guys.
It's okay.
I can't...
Okay, wait.
How do I get out of the store?
It's an expensive plushie.
It's okay.
I win it all back by gambling.
Come on.
Big money.
There's no way I could lose.
Okay.
I might be in debt, but I can get out of debt by gambling.
It's okay.
I can get out of...
Back out of...
I can get out of debt by gambling.
If you keep winning...
Oh.
I told you.
Yes.
XX.
Thank you for the 50 gift and ships.
Thank you.
Guys, we gotta get out of debt.
It's the only way.
Okay, guys, don't worry.
I could get out of debt, guys.
The lone shark that I borrowed this money from said that,
like, said, I just need to pay back by tonight, guys.
It's okay.
No.
I don't need my knees.
Oh!
Guys, it'll be fine.
It can't get worse.
it can't guys it can't get worse don't worry eventually i'll
hit it big you just gotta take more chances oh thank god
okay okay i can win again i can no don't gamble doky you
lose all your money what money i don't know if you see the
red sign on the top right court jester thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you over but I haven't finished
gambling the days oh I gotta borrow some money you spend
more than you'll have you'll have a wrecked racked up dead
and might even get visited by some scary people let's avoid
getting into dead oh thank god guys it's okay it's okay guys
my job my job clutched it out for me.
I need to enter.
Okay, I need to see.
I need to go see.
See, Kana.
Kana.
I shaved, brushed my teeth, and got the wrinkles out of my
clothes.
Okay, I'm good.
Let's go into the shop.
Keep gambling.
Wait, where's Kana?
She's away on Saturday!
Okay, notice up.
Don't go.
Don't go see.
Go to the garden on saturday why not having a conversation
with other cast it's not the same the cast member who likes
you the most will serve you immediately after you enter you
increase your like ability and you might end up like end up
with like marrying i know would marry me back joki you might
want to In game, 1-800-Gambler.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What drink did you want?
It's not the same.
Can I have a drink with you?
You don't even bother me up!
Okay, I'll give you... You're gonna have the same drink as
me.
You have to... You have to earn this.
You weren't my first.
So you have to try even harder to earn this money.
that I have here all 17,000 yen I really love this I mean
it's so yummy
whoa sorry guys you gotta extend your time if you okay um
let's have a conversation
Wait a second, you're pretty cute, but why are you curled in
a bowser?
What's wrong?
Well, I was here for Kana.
You don't even know my name.
You must be nervous.
That's no good.
Getting nervous over me is just a waste of energy.
Oh, hello.
My name is Haido Kanda.
It's a pleasure to make your acquaintance.
That's hilarious.
You start introducing yourself.
No, she's making fun of me.
Well then.
I will too.
Hello, I'm Rin.
I'm sorry to trouble you.
What am I doing?
Is this how it's supposed to go?
She's laughing at me, guys.
She makes me...
I feel emasculated.
So what do you do, Hi-chan?
But she called me Hi-chan, so it's all better now.
Well, right now, I'm assisting an acquaintance with their
job.
But until recently, I was employed at her company.
However...
How abusive.
Keep doing it.
Pyro!
That was due to plethora of mistakes, I was terminated.
Hang on.
Hai-chan, I can't keep up with all that formal speech.
I'd be super grateful if you just talk normally.
Hannah wouldn't laugh at me.
Really?
I'll drop the pretences then.
Thank you.
Thank yous.
You're such a nice guy, Haichan.
It's their loss for firing you.
You're better off without them.
You are right, Rin.
They made a fucking mistake.
No, oh, okay, never mind.
She's not right.
No, they treated me pretty well.
I'm getting by okay now.
Wow, you're really something, Haichan.
I respect that.
You're a stand-up guy.
You must get that a lot, huh?
Oh.
Let me hear some more.
I don't get that at all.
My self-esteem is so bad.
Why don't you help me out?
There it is again.
What's the name for it?
Humanity?
Oh, what was it?
It starts with age.
Humility!
That's it!
Oh, hey, let me tell you something.
I'm serious.
Well, I'm always serious.
But now I'm seriously serious.
Me and you people is really important, right?
In life, I mean, so I'm really grateful to have met you,
Hai-chan.
I may be far from perfect, but I'll still do the very best I
can.
I hope you're ready.
What?
God!
I'm embarrassing.
What am I saying?
I'm so silly.
Well, you get the idea.
Did you catch all that?
I won't say it again.
By the way, the other girls here are all really nice, too.
So I think you'll like the shop a lot.
oh my gosh she's so nice she knows that she's not for me she
doesn't care because i already spent money on her you find
i'm not your type after talking to me a few times feel free
to slide up to next to another girl instead oh it's because
she you know it's because she has all the customers she can
handle already she doesn't need more customers guys you know
rin has already got some high rollers she fucking knows she
knows i'm broke so she's encouraging me to look at other
girls because she's like oh this man bought me an 800 yen
this this man bought me an 800 yen glass of alcohol it's so
if you want to talk to other girls like she's too high count
she's too rich baby i'm not her i don't meet her standards
oh i miss kana she doesn't want to waste our time on small
fry i'm the small fry let me find out i'm your type it'd
make me pretty happy
Well, I'll leave it on that for now.
With that said, I'll look forward to serving you, Haichan.
Okay, I want to talk to Blue Girl here.
Oh, dang.
Time totally flies when I'm with you, Haichan.
What should I do?
Will you stay with me for a few more rounds?
No.
When did it get so late?
I guess I'll head back soon.
I just leave?
But I want to talk to her!
I want to talk to her!
What do you mean I just leave?
Thanks for everything.
See you soon.
No!
I can't believe it.
Guys.
Guys, I don't...
Guys, I'm so... Okay, maybe she'll be...
be back.
It's not Saturday, right?
Who's birthday?
Who's she?
Somebody's birthday?
Wait, what?
Okay.
Okay, there's nothing special.
It's Sunday.
Is she there?
Kana!
That is my time to rest up and recover.
This is the only place that can heal my mind.
Kana!
Kana, are you here?
Oh my god!
Wait, they're both the same size.
Oh my god It looks like they fucking Put a guacamole there
Thanks for visiting me today I meant same size ears guys I
meant same size ears Guys Their ears are the same size
Thanks for visiting me today What drink did you want I'll
take the I'll take the orange Then Oh don't we want to drink
too Kana Don't worry don't worry I saved up just for you
Kana Do you want the Bunny punch Okay I might be a little
I'm a little broke so Um Oh maybe some Vintage umeshu You
like that Oh she loves that Guys write it down This is what
Kana likes write it down the vintage kamashu
okay i'll give you guys what you okay kana kana kana kana i
bought you a gift kana i i bought you a gift what you do if
it's okay would you be willing to accept this i i hope you
like it oh i knew it i knew what women want Can I really
have it?
I'm so happy.
Thank you.
We have to take care of it.
What's wrong?
You seem puzzled.
Not now.
I'm concentrating really hard on something.
So don't talk to me right now.
Kana, why would you say that, Kana?
Huh?
I was gone for one day
Ka-kun You're Haito-kun Yip-Yep You definitely are There's
no mistake It's okay She's just being silly guys It's a joke
guys what you got you forgot my name and was desperately
trying to remember it guys no she didn't she didn't mean it
guys guys she didn't she was just joking with me right kana
see i knew it i knew she was joking that's not true i knew
from the very beginning i swear i mean you're an important
Of course I knew you wouldn't remember it, Kana.
I knew it.
I almost believed the haters out there.
But my dedication to you would never unwaver, Kana.
Even if your name slipped my mind, I remember it instantly.
Because you're Haito-Kun, and I know you are.
You're Haito-Kun, right?
Yes, I'm Haito-Kun.
I am...
Actually, I'm kind...
I am Haito.
I am Haito!
See?
I told you I'll get your name.
There's no way I'd forget it.
That was a relief.
JP, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No!
She was playing a funny joke on me and it was so funny.
Anyways, don't worry about me.
I'll never forget your name anymore, so don't worry, okay?
Of course, I'd never doubted you for the second, Kana.
Thanks, but I'm sure it's really hard for you to remember
every customer's name like that.
Exactly, guys.
She's a very busy girl, chat.
Like, she can't just remember all our names, you know?
Like, she's so busy.
This is her job, and it's okay if she makes a mistake or
two.
Yeah, I wish you all had name tags on or something, you
know?
That's something cute.
Like what you see a kindergartener wearing.
I know, Kat, you're so right.
It's our fault that you can't remember our names.
And I take full responsibility, Kana.
I'm only joking, of course.
I'm a pro in my field.
Remembering names is my specialty.
Well, you did remember my name within seconds before.
Seems like you're doing great from my eyes.
I am I'm so kind You really are kind aren't you Haito-kun
I'll make sure to never forget your name Look at that and
that's how you do it fellas That's how you you're in Oh my
gosh the way she looks at me though
When I'm with you Haito-kun do you think he'd of course of
course do i have the money yes i know i do
i thought you were going home of course not kana what drink
do i want i'll take the 800 guys i like how like they don't
tell you how much you spent so that's how they this is how
they get you as well what does she like again she liked um
right yeah she likes this what do i what i'm gonna buy it
again yes oh this is great i love this they knew they knew
they knew oh my god how much money did i spend i can't tell
they don't even tell you how much money you spend.
What do you like to eat?
I don't know if I have any particular favorites.
In fact, I'm really picky and I'll eat almost anything.
It's why I've been eating every day at the convenience store
so I can save my money for you, Kana.
You're seriously not picky at all?
Anything for you so you'd eat up sticks and stones if i
bring them to you that's amazing you might even go viral if
we film that of course you know what sticks and stones
aren't even that bad you can make soup out of it i'm i was
talking about edible things so what do you like to eat kana
chan
wait are you setting me up to make my food preferences into
a little quiz You know, I was just genuinely curious, but I
guess we could make it into a little game if you like.
Sounds great.
You know I love quizzes.
So what do you think my favorite food is?
Guys.
Is this going to be a trick question again?
Mr. Tooth, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Lucky for us, Doki.
We'll never forget our names.
After all, we have the name tags.
Told you it was a brilliant idea.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Sushi?
Oh, because she likes rice.
You're right, guys.
Our girl.
This is our girl.
We work together.
How about sushi?
When I go to sushi trains, I always end up making a tower of
empty plates.
I love sushi.
I can't stop eating it once I start.
I'm so hungry now that I started thinking about food.
Kana, do you want food, Kana?
Heyto, say something that would distract me, please.
At this rate, my head is going to end up being filled with
thoughts of food.
And I won't be able to concentrate on getting to know you.
Oh, do you want food?
Hmm?
Million stars shining in our solar system?
Stars?
Make a...
What?
Michelin?
Oh, Michelin stars!
It's like...
Kelvin?
Michelin stars!
No, I can't take my mind off food!
How about history then?
You know, famous Japanese battles?
I'm just sure that won't lead back to food.
how does she know about michelin stars oh no oh no she has
high taste guys history ancient times the edo period and
ninjas traditional japanese street food i guess anything i
say right now is just going to lead back to food somehow
Guys, do I have 3,000 yen?
Should I get you more drinks?
I can keep going, but only continue if I want to.
Guys, do I have 3,000 yen?
This is important.
No.
I'm sorry, Kana.
I'm broke for the day.
I'm sorry.
It's getting late.
I should go home soon.
But don't worry, I'll be back with more money.
Oh my god, definitely did not have 3,000 yet.
That's okay.
Another day of combinis.
Thank you for today.
See you soon.
I had a great fun conversation.
I'm looking forward to going.
work now oh my god thank you kana you made me richer i got
57 000 yen yay that means it's another day but what if i
guys guys okay don't guys all i'm saying is that is that as
everybody knows when it comes to gambling um you never quit
when you're ahead
way i could lose this time there's no way i i've hit all my
bad luck i used up all the bad luck so it's only up from now
it's red because it means good right oh it's okay it's only
10 000 guys it's only 10 000 yen so that means like this
next one this next one is gonna be like 20 000 plus and i'll
be up i'll be plused i knew it there you go i'm there you go
guys see You never end on a loss, chat.
You never end on a loss.
All right, let's see.
Plus 12,000 yen.
I'm going to buy another gift.
For Kana.
Should remember our names and it was based on food.
We'll see.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
I think, guys, I have enough for a necklace.
Oh my god, guys, guys, guys.
I have just enough for a necklace.
I think Kana would like this.
okay okay is today saturday okay guys we're gonna we're
gonna sleep guys because kana's not there
guys kana's not there so so we're gonna go sleep i still
have enough for a drink it's okay i'll sleep i'm gonna sleep
need food guys we don't need food we need all we need is
kana we'll eat we'll eat only only at the bunny garden now
is the time to rest up and recover this is the only place
that can heal my mind it's okay i'm back oh you came thanks
of course kana what drink did you want um i'll just take the
orange i'll just take the cheap one don't don't worry i know
what you like you like the guys how much money do i have
left guys guys how much money will always come for kana i
have 4 000 okay we're gonna her fine wine.
Maybe she'll like a fine wine.
That one...
She does!
Oh, this is great!
I love this!
She likes wine, too, and it's cheap.
It's a little cheaper.
Joshua, thank you for the magenta.
Super!
Thank you!
Doki, the slots call you.
Keep going.
Kana can wait.
The lights are calling.
D.
One person is only here for this game for the gambling.
Not for not for the main gameplay here Kana, Kana, I got
you, I got you some, a diamond necklace!
A diamond necklace?
Okay.
I did not realize I bought a diamond necklace.
If it's okay, would you be willing to accept this?
I hope you like it.
I didn't.
Can I really have it?
I'm so happy.
Thank you.
Of course you are, Kana.
We have to take care of it.
You seem happy.
Did something happen?
You came all this way to visit me, Haito-kun.
Of course I'm happy.
Of course, Kana.
I don't care about all these other ladies.
My eyes are only for you.
Thanks.
But, you see, much happier than usual.
Maybe it's because I already got some time to relax during
my time off recently.
Lloyd Kurosus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That weird feeling when your Oshi is losing tons of money to
a pretty girl when she doesn't have a huge amount of money
to spare right now.
Couldn't be me.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Because your day is off to the fullest then.
um oh um guys okay
i'll say slept in i'm gonna say it slept in my must right
no i don't know no i do know because i know what women like
Sleptin Sleptin I assume Oh I fucking knew it No Nicholas
You can't look at me like that It feels amazing to sleep
Without worrying about alarm The sleeping throughout the
whole day Feels like a bit of a waste You're too young You
don't understand the older you get sleeping in is a fucking
luxury I played with my bro There was no dog in this quiz,
but it's not your fault, Kana It's not your fault.
It had to be my fault.
I could have asked about the dog I played with my dog for
the whole day last time I had a day off Oh, you have a dog?
Uh-huh.
Oh, she has a chihuahua.
Not that I'll judge or anything.
He's a chihuahua called Wawa.
He's super cute.
And when you call him Wawa-chin, He wags his tail and comes
to you.
When he sleeps, it's always next to me, too.
Bro, like, I was just set up for failure.
He loves walks, too.
So I take him to this really big park near my place whenever
I get a day off.
That's what we did last time, too.
That sounds great.
I love dogs, too.
Really?
Well, I hope you give Wawa Chin a nice pat if you ever come
around.
I'm sure you'll end up enjoying his company, too.
Do you think he'd be fine around me, though?
I don't think so.
It's Chihuahua.
Chihuahua hate everybody, but they're owners.
I wonder who think I'm trying to take his master away from
him.
Who knows?
That could happen.
Wawa-chin loves me so much after all.
It should have been me.
You're trying to steal me away.
Oh, I didn't mean like, like, like that, Connor, but, but,
but, but, if that's what you, what you want.
What's wrong?
Nothing at all.
I'm feeling a little sweaty right now.
Actually, I wonder what's wrong with me Guys, do I have
enough guys?
Guys, guys, how much money do I have?
I don't.
I spent it.
No.
I don't have enough money.
I'm sorry.
I just have one session.
Okay, good.
Okay, but like, being in debt for a little bit will be okay.
It's okay.
I'm good for it.
I'm gonna stay a little bit longer.
It's just a little bit in the red.
I'm good for it.
They'll know.
I can pay them back.
What drink do you want?
I'll take the orange.
Oh, of course, Kana.
And then you can have, you can have the vintage.
It's okay just it's just a little bit in the red guys.
It's just a little bit They know I'm good for the money And
I don't need guys.
I have two kidneys.
That's all I'm saying
Guys I have two Let's see here you had soy ramen for lunch
didn't you?
How did you know?
Oh, no, I didn't I actually did, but I'm just playing with
her.
Forget that.
My vision wasn't fully accurate.
Of course you ate rice for lunch, didn't you?
I mean, I did, but I feel like rice is cheating when it's
used in some...
Haito, shut the fuck up, Haito.
We're supposed to agree with her.
Kobi, thank you for the super chat.
thank you debt is temporary kana is for exactly kana will be
there for me forever even if i'm broke right kana she'll
she'll be with me even if i was poor right guys joshua toky
go on it's time to ask her for the diamond necklace back and
bet it on black thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you most bento boxes has price as a side for one prediction
isn't all that impressive what are we even do why am i so
mean now
well i don't have anything i can call steel swords so i
thought i tried something else and the more impressive the
better right so i thought psychic readings would be so cool
oh no she is she an astrology girl it's a Okay, nobody's
perfect, guys.
Right, but you don't have any psychic powers, right?
I mean, clearly you don't.
Well, you couldn't predict what I ate.
Kaz, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Two kidneys?
You're right.
Imagine how many super chats I can send with that.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, I might be a late bloomer with my powers.
Why don't you think about all this after those powers bloom
then?
Guys, nobody's perfect!
But what would I do if someone asks if I have a party trick
then?
It's up to us to accept those flaws!
Except for me, I'm perfect.
Are you saying there isn't something you're super good at?
I mean...
There's nothing I can think of Where I'm better than the
average person I like acting and stuff But I'm not that good
Guys, why don't we even play Twisters?
It's not because Guys, I'm just Not because like This is
what I'm looking for But like I heard that there's Twister
And like, you know, it's a fun game Is there anything you
notice When looking at me, Haito-Kun?
for a really cool skill.
Guys, I just want to win, okay?
And I want to win at Twisters.
That's really it.
Let's see.
Well, you're very good at making people smile.
I'd call that a skill, Kana-chan.
Every time I see you, I get all happy, you know?
I'm guessing that's not what you wanted to hear at all.
No, that's exactly what I wanted to hear.
I just, I don't know what to say back to something like
that.
What do I do with you, Haito-Kun?
You're always like this.
You compliment me when I least expect.
I'm going to have a heart attack.
Sorry, I didn't say whatever is on my mind.
I'll try and stop myself from saying stuff like that from
now on.
That's right.
Always compliment the ladies.
That's even worse.
I'd love to hear you compliment me.
I'll make sure to live up to your standards too.
Like, I'll do my best to make you happy.
She just wants to make me happy.
It's not about the money.
I fucking knew.
I knew it, guys.
You guys were telling me to stay away from Kana.
That she is going to take advantage.
But she literally told me it's not about the money.
She's here for me.
still, right?
When I'm with you, Heiko, time just flies by like that.
Do you think you can?
Of course I can, Kana.
Time sure does fly by.
What drink did you want?
Okay, I'll take the cheap orange juice.
And then, and then, you can.
can get you know what i'm gonna splurge a little bit just
for you kana just for you i'm gonna get a uh uh i'm gonna
get like i'm gonna get just for you it's okay it's just 10
000 yen it's just she's happy it's all about making her
happy thank you i'll get you a bottle oh my god i told you
it's all oh my god i just the more expensive you order the
lower the fucking
i just i just noticed that the cheap drinks are up the cheap
drinks are like here or something but the expensive ones are
like here
that's how they get you you can also zoom in okay like um
it's not that like i don't know how to but like can you like
i feel like chat doesn't know so why don't you tell chat
like what button it is to zoom in for all the other gamers i
know what it is guys but um you for for all the other gamers
in chat you know i bet they don't know too um heydo kun do
you live by yourself yeah and you yep ever since i moved
into the city
well to be honest i guess i live in the family of two that
place is my chihuahua
That's true.
Dog's your family.
Gotcha.
Well, at least you won't feel lonely whenever you go home,
especially with someone that loves you that much waiting for
you.
You're totally right.
Wawa-chin really does boost my morale.
He's the main reason why I could do be my best ever since I
moved here.
And because he makes me so happy I need to do my part And
make his life as great as it can be A desire to make your
dog Have a wonderful life Huh?
God fuck Okay why are they harder now?
Okay I feel like you've already done that for him.
Okay, this has to be the right answer.
You know, I feel like you've already done that for him.
I hope he sees it that way.
I'll do my best to pamper him when I get home tonight, too.
I did it.
Guys, I did it.
I got the answer right.
I might take him to Dog Park next time.
I'm free.
outside after all.
When you talk about Wawa-chin, your face really lights up.
I can tell you cherish him deeply.
Wawa-chin is family to me, so of course I love him.
I'll introduce you to him if I get the chance we'll take...
Damn, guys.
Guys, that means she's gonna invite me to her house.
How else would I...
How else would I be introduced to the dog i'm allowed to
meet with your family we're in dragons putting like that
makes me feel a little nervous to be honest it feels like
i'm greeting your family before a wedding or something
that's just a joke but like unless uh-huh he might bark at
you saying i won't let you take kana Chan when it gets so
late no I don't know we still haven't done twister no oh my
god okay guys guys don't worry they know they know I'm good
for it guys do not worry now I'm more motivated to work
harder I'll be waiting for you so please come up of course
kana thank you for today
I feel way better today.
I'm ready to work hard now that I'm rested.
See, guys?
I'm ready to work hard because I'm rested now.
All right, Saturday.
Ooh, I gotta borrow some money.
No, I don't.
I just got paid.
Yes.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Today, I'm gonna go buy.
I'm gonna go buy.
Okay, I'm gonna buy her some macarons.
She must like macarons, right?
I'm gonna buy her some macarons.
and then um and then wait i can give the vacation you can
give vacation to cast member who invited you no a place to
travel okay kana doesn't work on saturday so so i just sleep
it's gamble time it's a gamble time no no don't no dokey do
not gamble just just head to bed do not do not gamble
You can go talk to Kana.
Now is my time to rest up and recover.
This is the only place that can heal my mind.
The job hub?
But like, but I want to talk to Kana.
I want to talk to Kana.
You came.
I'm glad.
Of course, Kana.
Anything for you.
Members, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Your friends are waiting at your apartment.
Doki, we need to talk.
This hostess bar thing.
It's killing you.
We looked around and found a rehab with nice slot machines
for you.
Let's go to tomorrow, okay?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'll just get the Cassie's orange and then kind of I know
you love the vintage Umashu.
I know you love that.
It tastes great.
If you job hunt, you can make more money.
Oh, it's cute.
No, I'm not.
Stop.
I just noticed the soup.
Guys, I vote.
Guys, it's because I I didn't miss out, guys.
Lucky macarons.
Alright.
You like macarons.
Will you be willing to accept this?
I hope you like it.
She does!
Guys, I have a feeling she just likes everything I give her.
I'll take care of it.
I've been really forgetful recently.
I saved a shopping list on my phone the other day too But I
completely forgot that I even made it when I got to the
store I always forget things when I'm tired too Santino they
give this super chat thank you thank you Use this for your
next gambling session Lord Kurosus this woman thinks we're
waiting wanting her When we really just want to pet the dog
until it loves us more than her They give this super chat
thank you thank you Look I would agree with that but she
owns a chihuahua And I look it's not that I don't like
chihuahuas, but all I'm saying is that I feel like out of
all the dogs in the world If if there was one dog that think
is like, you know, the personification of of the devil
If the devil was real, I think it would be the chihuahua The
other day I was planning on only having one bowl of rice
since I've been dining I'm it I've had three I feel like
that has nothing to do with forgetfulness You just gave into
your cravings
Like she's almost perfect Except for the fact that she
thinks she's psychic And also that she could be an astrology
girl And also like she owns a chihuahua She's like perfect
That's not true I just forget about the whole rule I set
myself when dieting
Oh, why don't I give you a quiz
So that you won't forget as much You know, using your brain
Leads to increase the memorization That's why I'm getting
What was I doing during my day off?
Oh, right, we were talking about that, weren't we?
That's right, you were saying What was kind of doing on her
day off?
Combine words while remembering previous conversation.
Women don't like...
Exactly, guys.
Women don't like it.
She went for a walk at the park with her dog.
There you go.
She went for a walk at the park.
Was it park?
Guys, of course.
Guys, I always remember, chat.
At the park with...
Was it the park, guys?
I was too...
Guys, I know, but I'm quizzing you guys.
Do you guys remember?
I knew the answer all along, chat.
Guys, I knew the answer all along.
I just wanted to know if you guys were listening.
Of course I remember.
I'm a woman.
I remember everything.
Bingo!
You really were listening.
to what I told you.
I like how you're so attached.
I know, of course.
Kana, of course.
I remember everything you say.
I need to be careful about being forgetful too.
Or else I'll never be able to go through a dieting.
I keep saying, that has nothing to do with memorization.
I think it's your willpower that you need to work on.
I don't know!
This is not how you fucking get the ladies!
You'd never criticize them especially about dieting kata's
just like let me ignore that because i want you to spend
more money should i get you more drinks i can keep going but
only continue if you want to yes i have the money this time
thank you i thought you're going of course i would never go
home i'll fucking max it out for you what drink i'll just
let me keep you know what i feel a little adventurous i feel
I feel so adventurous right now.
I'll spend 100 yen more.
And then for you, my queen, I'm going to...
You know what?
I'm going to...
I'm going to give you the fine wine.
Yep, yep, it tastes great.
Anyway, yep, yep, it tastes great.
Wait, it just tastes great?
It's just...
It's just great?
Wait.
No, I pressed Q instead of E.
I keep forgetting.
I keep...
I don't know how to read.
I saw Zoom.
I didn't see it Zoom out.
Q was Zoom out.
E was Zoom in.
But I didn't read it fully.
I just saw Zoom.
I had a nightmare for the first time and forever last night.
I woke up screaming in the middle of the night.
Oh, seriously?
What kind of dream was it?
That you weren't there, baby girl.
Whoa.
Well, I had become a kid.
And I was enjoying my summer vacation.
You know, catching bugs and swimming in the river.
Kind of like when I went to my grandma's place to spend the
summer
wait who did the throw up emote oh lord you don't understand
this is why you don't have kana wait what about this is that
is a nightmare I mean that sounds pretty fun to me right I
thought so too in the beginning but then the moment said I
wish my summer vacation will go on forever and that forever
didn't include you boom oh wait a giant version of my boss
crawled out of the soil and said i'll give you a vacation
for the rest of their life you're fired i like someone
pregnant emoji right anyone would wake up screaming after
that
out but i guess me getting fired really got me emotionally
you're not to blame though i mean sure you were genuinely
shocked it takes time for emotional wounds to heal you're so
right kana uh free thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you bunny girls i enjoyed your company sir credit card
declines bunny girls low tier god lighting appears around
them You should...
I know that, but I just want to forget it.
How about this?
I'll make you forget those bad memories!
Are you saying you're going to cheer me up somehow?
You really are kind to the core, Hana.
A special drink?
It'll only cost you, like, the rest of your money.
I think there's a special drink we hid away in the shop's
storage.
I'm sure you take a sip.
Your memory will fade away in an instant.
I prefer not to forget with something like that.
Of course, I just need more time with you, so you'll get me
the special drink, right?
Right, Hakana?
Is that it?
I'll take the orange juice.
Of course, of course.
And you can get the vintage Umashu because I know that's
what you love.
Yep, yep, it tastes great.
No, I keep...
Guys, I need to buy new drinks.
She's already too used to the Umashu.
We're looking respectfully.
conversation what if like i buy food this time well buying
food like increase it okay why do you want to share a pizza
with me with me conna we can share pizza together oh this is
great i love this
That's so much going on today That was...
Oh my god, you're right, I should have got sushi!
It's our favorite!
You're so right!
Oh my god, this is why this is a group effort.
If all of us work together, if all the dragoons work
together, we surely might score one kana.
You took your day off to sing, and here I am complaining.
Don't worry about it, you should relax when you get home.
It's not good to pile up your fatigue and leave it be.
Yeah,
good plan.
Thanks, Haighto-Kun.
It's like we're all at the same bar.
Exactly.
You're like my wingman.
You're all behind me.
Wingmanning me.
Do you have some sort of method to get rid of fatigue?
Something easy will be great if possible.
Not the naps.
Naps never work.
Okay, never.
Not the naps.
We learned.
We learned that.
That napping does not help at all.
How about eating something sweet?
How about getting a massage?
A massage.
Okay.
I'm going to say a massage.
How about getting a massage?
Not by me, of course.
But like, if you insist.
Oh, a massage?
Would be great.
Maybe I should buy a massage device.
I hope there's something that's easy to use at home.
She liked that answer, guys.
We did it.
We're so in.
Oh, and you can't forget taking a nice warm bath, too.
Just sitting there in the warm water as your pain slowly
fades away.
Oh, you know, we could, you know, we can go to the hot
springs.
Whoa.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm talking about the hot springs.
imagine me in the bathtub that's some forbidden territory
you can whoa bro what the fuck am i getting caught out for
my imagination that didn't totally happen like you don't
know that what do you mean me she doesn't know what i was
thinking about you were the one that brought it up
Where do you wash first when you're in the bath?
My hair.
What?
What hair?
Do you not wash your hair first?
That's where the water touches first.
How is that bad?
Wait, forget I even asked that.
The you and my mind has started to strip.
What?
whoa next see bro she's she's going she's going further than
what i was just thinking about the the hair of my head oh my
god we're living rent-free we're so in next see we know what
you're thinking about what was i thinking about thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you i can't i can't have
that happen in my head, Haito-Kun.
Don't blame me.
You're the one who's imagining the whole scenario.
Doesn't you get to play Twister now?
Is it already this late?
I'll head back.
No!
Haito!
We were so in!
You don't leave when you're like literally there!
Haito!
You're so fucking stupid, Haito!
Oh my god You don't just leave But you're literally there
I'll be waiting for you So please come again Yes thank you
for today Yay We had a good fun conversation Alright we're
trying to get a better job right Alright All right, is it
job hunting time?
Can I actually get a better job, chat?
Oh, I hate though.
The fumble is so fucking crazy.
I need a note.
Do I actually get a better job, chat?
Yes?
Okay.
By applying on a dispatch recruitment date, you can earn
money.
One dispatch consumes 2K.
Be careful not to overwork.
All right, do you want to spend two days on dispatch?
Yes.
Let's do it.
I'm working.
Oh, $71,000 yen.
Oh, my God.
This is so much.
Oh, thank you for your hard work.
Oh, my God.
No, no.
I missed that week.
I missed that.
No.
Kana, please don't forget me, Kana.
I'm going to get, I'm going to buy her some perfumes.
And I'm going to buy her, I'm going to buy her, pajamas and
then and then i'm gonna buy her roses okay i have gifts for
all three days okay we missed okay it's okay Saturday she's
not there on saturday so we're gonna go gambling no do you
think she forgot about me guys wait do you think no it's
still not open okay okay okay we're gonna we're gonna gamble
guys guys no we don't need a save guys we're not save
scumming chat we're not save scumming guys this is it this
is it we must we we're so lucky right now we have so much
money right now chat this is it no we're not gonna save guys
we don't need a save because we're gonna earn go up yes okay
that's good i'll take that 2000 yen
We're going to cash out.
I'm scared.
I'm too scared to keep going.
Bro, she takes a break on Saturday.
What the fuck's the point?
Okay, we're going to sleep in and see her on Sunday.
Alright, that was a bit scary.
Yeah, we're going to sleep in.
She's going to be there on Sunday.
I'll always show up on Sunday.
No, we don't need a save, guys.
We don't need a save.
my teeth and got the wrinkles out of my clothes.
Okay, I'm good.
Let's go into the shop.
Kana, I'm back!
Do you remember me, Kana?
Of course, of course, Kana.
Don't worry, I'm gonna...
Kana, today it's Big Money Day.
Today it's Big... Okay, maybe not that big.
maybe maybe not that big money i just realized it's a
hundred well we'll go with the lamp it's it's second big
money day it's almost big money day today is i own money day
i'm not ready yet i'm of course i'm ready guys I'm ready.
Oh, it's all the way down there.
Kana, Kana, I...
Kana, I got you perfume, Kana.
Hanover.
Will you be willing to accept this, Kana?
Ah, she likes it.
I'll take care of it, of course.
kind of is your blood type oh yeah there's like in asia
cultures like a blood type is like a personality trait
actually is how did you know well you have a carefree vibe
about you i know especially with money right so you based it
off of a blood type personality test i don't know how
accurate something like that is
Well, whether you believe it or not isn't important, what's
important is that I can lead the conversation.
Well, let's see, would your blood type be?
Guys, okay, I actually don't like care about the blood type
person.
Holy shit!
So, I see that like astrology.
Let's see, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All this, and you're somehow less of a simp than you are an
adventure thank you with the super chat thank you thank you
guys what is a good blood type what is a good one
is it a b a b i don't know what the blood types are a b is
supposed to be the ganky one we use them my a b is normal so
probably b is more common a b is the universal recipient AB
is good because it's a universal recipient guys AB is
superior A is for kind people AB is two-faced always guys I
feel like a lot of you guys don't even know as well okay A
or B I'm gonna go with A I'm gonna go with A because A is
always a a good blood type right A perhaps Yes!
Are you suggesting I'm a methodical person, serious and
sincere too?
I knew it.
My Asian genes spoke to me because A is always better than
B.
I mean, serious and sincere too?
You know me too well.
We're so in.
The correct answer was O type the same.
Okay, I didn't even get that as a choice.
I don't care too much about the details.
And I'm pretty easy going, wouldn't you say?
Well, when you put it that way, I suppose I see that inside
of you.
But if I said you were methodical or emotional, for example,
you feel that way too, right?
I guess you're right.
Sorry, I thought it could be...
Oh my gosh, why am I so bad at this?
Why is Haito...
Haito, I worked so hard trying to get you, Kana.
But you always fuck it up.
Why do you do this to me?
I spent so much of our money for her.
No, I should be the one apologizing.
You went through all that trouble thinking up with someone
to talk about.
Right, what blood type are your parents?
My dad is A and my mom is B.
I don't know why you're bringing this up where the
personalities are nothing like the readings.
I don't know!
I even bought her the second most expensive wine!
Sorry, I can't even control this!
Bro, I can't control incompetence!
I'll do my best not to ruin the vibes like that again.
Gambit, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Blood-type tomato juice.
Self-sabotage.
I just want to tease you a little return.
all whoopsie of course of course kana let's get more twinks
all right i'll drink the cassie's orange and then you you go
okay look i already gave you like the second most expensive
so we're gonna we're just gonna go back to the usual well
why don't we try uh why don't we try bunny trap We can
afford a little splurge.
Yep, yep, it tastes great.
Alright.
We'll look at the most respectable part of the body.
The hair.
I can't give any more presents today.
Oh, don't worry, we can buy sushi.
We can buy sushi because I know how much you love sushi.
And I have the extra money right now.
Yep, yep, it tastes great.
Kana, didn't you say that?
You're perfect.
Ice cream, cake, nah.
Mochi is an option too.
Damn you, Toki.
Are you thinking about what to have for dessert when you get
home?
She's always hungry.
How did you know?
That looked like I was that hungry for some sugary treats?
I mean, you were the one mothering about it, though.
I guess you didn't realize that you said that.
I want to eat all three, to be honest.
Ice cream, cake, mochi, they're all amazing.
I know I could destroy all three in the heartbeat.
I did something so extreme at night.
I know I'll wake up in the middle of night with nothing but
regret for my actions.
Well, eating too much is never good for your body either.
You should probably just choose the one.
Guys, what do you think she likes the most, guys?
Does she ever tell me what she...
She never told me what dessert she likes the most!
How am I... Okay, what's the best dessert?
How about cake?
Mochi, cake, ice cream?
Okay.
Cake.
It has to be cake, right?
cake is is universally loved there's so many different
flavors with cake i actually bought some chocolate cake last
night so i need to eat it while it's fresh yeah that's
definitely i did it i knew it i made the right choice
without any help whatsoever
maybe i should just eat it all i can't decide i love them
all equally
Nice guest, Doki.
It's not a guest.
I know the way to Kana's heart and not you.
And there may be enjoyed after all.
I think it's my civil duty to enjoy them all to their
fullest.
Yep, that's my civil duty.
Oh my gosh, that was a very long sentence she said for, my
civil duty i'm worried you're gonna have an upset stomach by
the end of this can you keep drinking heito don't of course
i can anything for you i'll stay here forever of course i'll
take my i'm gonna be a little adventurous guys and i think
i'm gonna get some beer i'll be i'll spend i'll spend like a
hundred yen more
It's just 100 yen more.
Well, looking at her hair.
All right, conversation time.
All right, so what do you have when you...
So what do you do when you have spare time at home?
I always play with Wawa-chin, my Chihuahua.
I'll start to play with him and by the time I realize it
ends up being the dead of night.
If anything, maybe Wawa-chin is looking after you.
What do you do at home, Haito-kun?
Well, video games for one.
I'll play on console.
I'll play on a car.
Oh my gosh.
I have hit rock bottom.
I'll play on a console I have at home Then play a little bit
on my phone.
Oh, no, I'm also a gotcha gamer before I sleep Where's my
PC?
I have a PC What happened to steam?
I'm literally playing this on steam Games Kana You not like
video games Kana After I spent like I'm pretty sure I spent
like more than 5k on her like american 5 000 and now you're
gonna tell me games huh oh do you dislike video games kind
of please answer wisely kind of oh oh thank god i was gonna
say that was my deal breaker it would have been over console
is cool too yes but not just console i need to expand You
need to expand them!
There's also PC gaming!
Ha ha ha!
Nope, I love them actually.
But that's exactly why I made myself stop playing.
And I end up being really loud, you see.
Oh, is it because of...
Don't worry, my apartment has soundproofs, so if you...
Wait, no, that's not what I mean!
For gaming!
So neighbors won't complain for gaming!
I won't say things like I'll get your damn you I will oh my
gosh she's toxic she's perfect you know the usual
Am I try to hold back I'll be back to shutting by the time I
realized it
That's why I forced myself to stop playing I don't want to
cause any disturbances to my neighbors, you know.
That's what I heard.
I heard in Japan, it's really hard to get, like, a place
that was soundproofing for streamers.
Because, like, you know, especially, like, streamers are,
like, really loud and stuff.
Like, you can get, like, called on by the police and stuff
very easily.
That's a bit of a shame.
I never knew you were so passionate.
Oh, my God.
Thank God she's perfect.
I thought she was going to judge me for my gaming.
I was ready to go to another girl.
I was so fucking ready to be, like, bye.
don't you play puzzle games instead of something that's so
action focused you know something that uses your height
though what the fuck why would you suggest puzzle game oh my
god heighto does not represent me
i would have walked away
it's all the same i end up being overly passionate even if
i'm solving a puzzle Super chat, thank you, thank you.
Kana says gamer words.
I'll be allowed for being so hyper after beating a tough
puzzle.
And similarly, I'll be allowed if I can beat a harder
In a way, I'm jealous of how passionate you are towards
video games.
Oh my god.
I'll buy you one right now.
Who cares if I need the loan money, Kana?
If I ever become rich, I'll buy a soundproof room.
And then I'll play video games to my heart's content.
So I'll be patient for now.
Do you want something to take with you?
You know, maybe something that symbolizes our friendship.
I have something perfect.
What?
Yes?
Yes, Kana?
Oh!
Okay.
It's time.
Oh my god.
Cast members may invite you to play mini games.
You can pay a fee.
All right.
And enjoy.
She's like, can I invite you after hours?
By the way, it'll be 100,000 yen.
Oh, a polar...
Yes, yes.
Of course.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna get a Polaroid photo.
This is not Twister.
You select the pose and take a photo.
You can check the photos you took from your home.
As your likability increases, the number of pose increases
as well.
Okay.
Oh!
What the fuck does chicken...
Guys, I think I know what chicken meat means.
um let's see i don't know i'm trying to figure out the best
one okay no this one her hands i don't like where her hat i
don't like like where i don't i don't like where her hands
are all right Maybe...
Bunny ears?
Bunny ears, right?
Uh...
I don't know, guys.
Or...
But...
I'm trying to decide.
It's so difficult!
What the fuck is chicken?
You know what the fuck chicken meat is.
You know...
Don't act ignorant to me about chicken meat.
kidding me okay maybe we'll do we'll do uh you know what
okay let's see wait guys we're here for the eyes right we're
here for the eyes oh what about like okay oh look at that
beautiful hand
Okay, what about the hands, though?
Guys, what about the hands?
Oh, what?
No, that didn't mean to!
No!
There's a time for me!
This is nice.
I didn't know that.
Glad you came again, Connor.
Oh, my.
Tell us, Doki, what does this mean?
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
thank you oh my god i thought i could drink
i hope you have beautiful hands kana
guys this is all i wanted you it was fun wasn't it i was
setting i was sweating a little uh oh could they give us
late i should go home soon oh my that was so much money yes
she's happy though i'll be waiting for you so please come
back again yes thank you for today thank you conno yay i get
to drink delicious alcohol and have fun conversations now
i'm motivated for work hon george thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you 100 safe for work nice dokey how is
i supposed to know guys we have to earn money guys we need
money guys we have to work for kana kind of don't forget
about me kana i'm earning more money for you okay thank you
for your hard work all right
Okay, nice.
Alright.
What should I drink today?
Beer, wine, champagne.
Let's just get in there first.
Kana, Kana, Kana.
She's here!
She was waiting!
For me!
I'll get the Cassie's orange, please.
Of course.
Can I...
You know what?
I think this will get me the twister.
I think this will get me twister guys.
I'm gonna do it guys guys guys guys guys.
I'm gonna do it I would get twister.
I'm I'm pretty sure guys it's okay a little bit of debt is
okay guys it'll just be a little bit of debt it's actually
over it doesn't work like that what do you mean It's not the
time.
Yes, but it's okay.
I can go into a little bit of debt.
It's fine.
I swear.
It's too dangerous.
You guys are cowards.
Olive, if you don't spend it all for your one true hostess,
then what's the point?
Do it for her.
Really?
I'll get you a bottle!
Do it for her!
Whoa!
It's a different color!
Kana, Kana, Kana.
I also got you pajamas.
It's okay.
Will you be willing to accept this?
Accept this?
I hope you like it.
Can I really have it?
I'm so happy.
Thank you.
Of course, Kana!
Anything for you?
There's something I want to talk to you about.
What is it?
What is it, Kana?
It's okay.
I have two livers.
No, wait.
No, I have one.
I have two kidneys, two eyes, two ears, two hands, two feet.
I don't need two.
One can do the job.
actually forget I mentioned it no no tell me I spent a
hundred I spent a hundred and eighty thousand yen on you for
my one true doki I guess thank you for the super chat
sentina thank you thank you two lines I can live with half a
liver this time is to make you feel good haito kun so I
can't go and bring my own issues no no I'm a good listener,
Kano.
Not at all.
I'll do anything I can to listen to your problems.
Thanks, Haida-Kun.
I might take your offer of kindness then.
I have ten fingers.
I don't need ten fingers.
Yeah, your liver regrows, technically.
My dad from back in the countryside called me.
He told me to come back.
But there's still so much I want to do here.
So I told him that I won't return home.
Don't listen to your father.
Listen to me.
I see.
I'm sure he's just worried about his own daughter who lives
so far away from him.
I can donate so much.
Anything for Kano.
I know, but that's exactly why I feel a little guilty.
when I mentioned not wanting to come back.
I'll be your...
I'll be your new dad.
Hold on.
I never talked to you about my family back home, right?
Cass, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm learning so many new stats from the stream.
All these unnecessary organs I never see anyway.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I remember you bringing them up briefly.
Remember when we talked about blood types?
Let's see.
Oh.
Dad and mom are A and B, right?
Dad and mom.
Guys, I know the answer.
But do you know the answer?
Guys, I know what the answers are.
But do you know what it is?
I'm gonna test you guys.
What was it?
Yeah, yeah, you do.
Oh, yeah, prove it.
Prove that you know the answer, chat.
Unless you're lying to me.
Whereas I always knew.
I already knew.
Oh, wow.
I can't believe you even remembered that.
I'm kind of happy that you knew it.
Of course, Kana.
at least $10,000 on you, I'll always remember.
I'm making my dad sad, aren't I?
I don't want him to feel that way at all.
I won't deny that he doesn't feel sad, but I'm sure he'll
come back to understand your desire to stay there.
I mean, you're telling how you really feel after all.
He'll be proud of you, except your viewpoint for sure.
Haito-Kun, thanks.
Of course!
Of course, Kana!
I can't go home yet because I need to still achieve my goals
here.
But do my... What goals?
I'm actually curious what the goals are.
I'll do my best not to make my dad feel sad too.
Maybe I should call him more often.
Oh, and I have to mention you to him too, of course.
Yes, that's all dads want to hear.
The guy that's giving so much money to his daughter for her
to give attention to him.
That's what all dads want to hear in the countryside.
I'll tell him how much you uplift me whenever we talk with
money
oh but I tell my dad that he might take it in the wrong way
you don't like that would you
maybe I'll stay quiet about you for the time being then no
what i don't want to be your secret i want to be public kana
kana i already told my mom about you kana should i get you
more drinks and you of course yes yes a little bit of debt
won't hurt anybody i'm gonna be so happy later okay i can't
afford much right now all right apparently somebody said get
the high the special high ball because like um that's like
her favorite so i believe you it tastes amazing i love this
i fucking knew it that someone was me i told myself that all
right her beautiful her okay her beautiful bunny tail okay i
already gave her a present right so um um should we have it
let's have food okay food We'll have...
You know what?
We'll have...
You know, we'll try candies.
She likes sweet stuff.
This is great.
I love this.
Skelem, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Who paid money for attention?
Weird.
Toki, decide for me, please.
Should I make a ginger chewy cookie?
Or hazelnut brown butter cake?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You know what?
Get the brown butter cake.
Kana likes cake.
like cake i already bought sushi she didn't give me like a
nice answer i feel like my hair is getting kind of long make
sure maybe i should book an appointment at the hairdresser
soon how much would it cost i got you like
short or long or something i don't think i have any sort of
preference like that i like i like kana shaped hair how
about hair color then do you like brighter tones or nice but
so are darker ones
look my entire preferences is just you now okay i i'm a
little annoyed at how much you don't seem to care all that
much hey don't you fucking blew it it's like how like girls
are like do you notice anything different and the guys are
just your hair I think you can at least seem a little more
interested You know It feels like you don't care about my
hair at all Sorry I wasn't trying to say that at all I'm
saying that you could pull off any hairstyle or color I
really don't mean that I really do mean that Sorry I really
do mean that
Of course You're doubting me already Bought you the fucking
150k yen champagne.
And I only had 146.
I do.
Besides not having a preference isn't necessarily a bad
thing, is it?
That means you can make anything work, Kana.
I can promise you that no matter what hairstyle you decide
to go with, I'll visit you the same amount as always.
Look, I haven't even talked to another woman.
I only talked to you, Kana.
I'm sure I'll become more attracted to you going forward,
but I'll never start disliking you because you change your
appearance That's so unfair, Haito-Kun I can't say anything
back when you say something so kind like, Oh my god, Haito,
you did it.
You finally clutched it for once in your life Of course, of
course, let's talk more
all right i'll get my i'll you know what i'll change it up
i'll get the ulong hi-ba and then i know you love the
special hi-ba it tastes amazing i love this
yay her beautiful hair that we all love and her beautiful
hands that have a photo of
Okay, I'm not reading that out.
What are you doing?
You know, this job is all about talking with others, right?
So I do all sorts of vocal exercises.
So I don't mess up my words.
Oh, your enunciation, huh?
I suppose that would make sense to practice so you don't
fumble your sentences.
I say as I never practice and now you can tell why I You can
tell why I pronounce things the way I do She sells seashells
by the seashore Okay, that is definitely not it
That's definitely not the translation to what she said
Tongue twisters impressive You didn't even stumble,
Kana-chan Okay, I'm sorry
I used to be in the drama club back in the day, actually.
We used to do this sort of practice all the time.
Kanachan, you were in the drama club?
Now I'm curious.
Were you always...
Did you mainly practice acting?
Okay, I don't think I should say these.
Okay, did you mainly practice acting?
practice acting?
You're not an actor?
Why the fuck were you doing fucking word exercise?
Why the fuck?
Of course I would assume you're an actor for doing word
exercise.
I was on the sound team.
And I was literally I was like the sound I was a
behind-the-scenes sound team we did not practice fucking
sound exercise actors are the pinnacle what most people in
drama want to become aren't they but I wasn't like that I
was part of the lighting crew I was like lighting and sound
I was part of the lighting and sound crew given the actors
their spotlight and thinking about light and whatnot mostly
on the lights though i worked mostly on the lights but if we
needed if our sound guy wasn't there like i would like
attempt to do the sound because i had like seniority but i
was like i was what was it called like the the crew the crew
in charge the behind the scenes crew i actually got like uh
back then okay sorry kana this is my time to share my story
but like back then I think in like in high school there was
a convention slash conference for like um theater people one
time I was selected for like the drama side but like the
second time I was selected to do the behind the scenes and
like only several students uh I think like only three people
are selected per school to go represent the school for this
like uh drama conference or whatever and basically like each
school select three students one will be the band One will
be like the, from the band class, one will be in the acting,
and the other will be like the technician.
So I got selected for, one time I got selected for acting,
and then the other time I got selected for a technician.
So like, I've done like technician and acting for the
conference.
And then it's basically all the students from each school
come together and produce like some show.
Like it's there to like improve your knowledge.
It's to improve your knowledge and your skill set.
come together like all like each school comes together to
make this giant show based off of like um all these like
really talented individuals in each like sector and uh and
that's why this is it's so fucking bullshit that she was
like i was part of the lightning lightning crew and she's
trying to like bait me with the pronunciation like how is i
supposed to know she was in lightning how how is i supposed
to know she was in lighting if she talked about
pronunciation and tongue
I see I just assumed that most people in the drama club
Would want to act more than anything Fucking poser Tell you
the honest truth
I want to act too Look guys this is why I'm not an actor I
don't do ton twisters Of course I fumble with my words She
was right I fumble with my words That's why I going to begin
with.
Sira, thank you.
Sira's Lee, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Girl could come back.
Thank you for a super chat, by the way.
Girl could come back looking like a tomato.
Little does she know we're into that.
Thank you for existing, Doki.
I didn't have the crew should act in front of an audience.
So I panicked and went for the lighting crew position
instead.
Don't get me wrong.
I enjoyed doing the lighting
I really did give it my all while learning the importance of
behind the scenes work Also for the conference like you we
had to travel so it's not like in our area The school would
like pay for like the travel cost to whatever school was
hosting it at that time But because I was working behind the
scenes I could see the actor perform in the spotlight from
so close So we would like travel really far at one point.
My dreams kept getting bigger and bigger while me really
striving towards them.
And that brings me to the day, I guess.
I love to see you in action one of these days.
Working on the lights, Kana-chan.
She's told you she wants to be a fucking actor.
Well,
I guess I could do my best to try once again.
I hope one day I can bring you the good news that I'm back
at it.
Yes!
Oh, come on.
Twister, twister, twister, twister.
Yeah.
I'm sure you'll have fun if you went through with it.
Come on, let's do it.
Oh my god, yes.
Please not be the hand game.
It's a 50-50.
Yes!
You can spin the roulette every time you pay a fee in the
castle.
Move their limbs according to the instructions given on the
roulette wheel.
Have fun and see how long you can last.
Alright, let's start.
Okay, you first go, Kana-chan.
Right hand on yellow.
Oh my god!
have an over.
Whoa.
Okay, yes, spin the roulette.
I can keep going.
Left foot on red.
Whoa!
What the fuck?
I'm sure dad is very happy about your job.
Whoa!
Okay.
Spinning in.
I won the 55.
50 guys all right left hand on yellow there we go can i like
okay yeah okay there we go there we go spin the roulette yes
cute i guess we keep spinning
right foot on red where's the oh god
Guys, I'm gonna I'm gonna look up
Okay, I feel I feel like you don't know
Yeah, so lower angle you be like this right?
There we go Okay, right foot on okay Guys, guys, I feel
like, guys, okay, I feel like I need to step in real fast.
There we go.
Okay.
Oh, but I got this.
What do you mean?
Oh, I'm sorry.
You don't want me here?
It was fun, wasn't it?
I was sweating a little.
I've been so locked.
I've been so locked in in my life.
When it gets so late, I guess I'll head back soon.
Oh my god.
Oh, hey, nice.
Nice.
Alright.
I want to be a little longer.
Oh my god.
Go so in.
I don't want to just say bye to you now.
But I don't want you to feel pressured by now either.
When the cast members are in a good mood.
You might be invited.
to afters?
Going out with the cast members outside the shop?
It's soon that you'll treat, of course.
I'll do it.
It'll cost you to go after.
Yes, let's go somewhere right now.
Okay, guys, we're gonna do it.
Let's go somewhere.
Really?
I guess you wanted to be with me some boy.
Guys, we got to!
She wants to do after hours no you're blocking kind of
episode thank you with a super chat thank you thank you this
is my gambling i'll leave the location up to you i know be
fun no matter where we go if i'm with you okay she's gonna
get ready she's gonna change
oh my god i'm so in oh my god why are you crying why is it
because i'm broke Okay, content, just use my handkerchief.
Oh, my God.
Where are we going to go with negative cash?
Don't look at my face too much.
Anything else, you can cry this much?
My face looks awful.
Oh, did we just finish watching a movie?
That was amazing.
I think this has definitely landed my top three movies now.
Oh, guys, I don't even get to see that movie.
That's how broke I was.
They cut off the movie content.
Your face?
I think so too.
I like this director's previous work, but this might be my
favorite.
You sure know your movies, Kana-chan.
I'm trying to be an actress, remember?
I watch a bunch of movies.
But movies are definitely more fun to watch with friends
rather than by yourself.
and talk about your thoughts afterwards about things you
liked or what scenes did that sort of thing is super fun
usually I watch things by myself but you might be right
about this one Kana-chan oh my gosh she's going to jumbo it
I need to write a review of this movie the moment I get home
you write reviews
yep i write them down to journal my thoughts things like
which scenes i remember or which actor stood out are you
gonna write about the twister but today's journaling might
end up being a bit more than just a movie review oh no she's
gonna write about the twister what do you
Another 15k for the movie.
Because I watched it with you.
I feel like I'm going to end up writing more about my time
with you.
Just please don't show it to your dad, Kana.
Just don't let your family see your journal.
That's all I ask.
I'd love to read the end result.
Nope, not even a sentence because it's a secret.
Oh God.
Oh my god, it's nighttime!
She's gonna give me a gift!
Oh, birthday ticket!
Is this an invitation to your birthday?
Her birthday is coming up!
Wait, what do we get to do on her birthday?
Why is Doki in the- you know why?
You know why it's in the raid.
Thanks, Kana-chan.
The movie you saw today was amazing.
Wait, I have to save up for it?
What do you mean?
You had to...
You get to buy her presents?
Did you...
Of course I did.
Because I was with you.
Right.
There's another movie around the corner that looks really
good.
I hope we can watch that one together.
I need to go home to see you while watching you say safe
going home too okay right tell while watching I said hi I'll
see you later oh my god I did I have an after fees okay
that's that's really it was that hundred and fifty dollars
how fucking expensive was Why is the club charging me the
money?
Why is the hostess club charging me the ad?
Isn't that 100, 150 US?
Or like 100.
Why is the movie so?
It's 100.
Why is it $100 for the movie?
Movie tickets are like, I don't know, $20.
30?
At least, hey, I feel so good at work.
Did you buy snacks?
I got the...
I spent way too much money.
I don't have enough money.
I need to borrow.
Oh my god.
When is her birthday?
It literally doesn't... Okay.
It's on August 13th.
Wait, what's the shop?
Oh my God!
Oh my god, when are you ever gonna wear this dress?
A hundred and fifty.
Oh my god.
Guys, I think this...
Guys, I got to play Twister.
I think this is a good time to call it.
I got what I wanted.
guys i guys i got i got twister i think that's okay
that's we peaked guys guys we peaked from there we all we
wanted to do was play twister i think that was the perfect
time to call it i think that he was doing cute Daisy, thank
you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, I'm fucking, I'm in debt right now.
I can't buy anything.
I'm literally in debt.
Chat.
Guys, it's okay.
I had a good day.
Mani, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki, I'm 200,000 yen in debt from host clubs and the
collectors are busting down my door to break my kneecaps.
Let's go!
Thanks for the stream.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys.
Guys, we lost so much money, but it was all for Kana.
It was all for Kana.
The best girl.
We did it, chat.
We fucking did it.
It's okay, guys.
It's okay.
We made it.
We peaked.
I feel so motivated, chat.
I feel so fucking motivated now.
Well, that was, that was an adventure, guys.
That truly was an adventure.
I think it was good that we didn't keep going.
Because I'm worried that I think the mafia was actually
going to go for me if I kept going.
So, like, we gotta, we gotta know when to quit, you know.
We gotta, we gotta, we gotta, because, because I think I
like my body organs.
you know thought about it and like i feel like maybe i do
need two kidneys you know chat maybe maybe i do need both my
kidneys and both my lungs i don't know just just a maybe uh
rumpa thank you for the super chat thank you thank you uh
wow dokey you're just gonna twist her and leave yes
absolutely after kana fucking charged me a hundred dollars
for the fucking movie tickets I don't know, guys.
Like, I thought she was perfect, but then she buys movie
snacks.
So, like...
So, I don't know.
I feel like that's a little bit of a red flag.
That's a little bit of...
She buys $100 worth of movie snacks.
So, like, I feel like it's a little bit of a red flag, guys.
Echo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Imagine being dead from a gotcha game.
Conan V.
Doki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
She bought sort of like $60 worth of movie food.
And that's like one popcorn and a Coke.
And like at that point, I feel like, you know, Kana might be
a little too rich for me.
For my taste.
Granny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Broken bun.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Got a gamble to make even for Kana's birthday.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Glad to know Doki has the same spending habits we do.
It's reassuring knowing we're all broke together.
Thank you.
You know what?
It wouldn't hurt to gamble, right?
We're, all right.
Guys.
Guys, okay.
We're just gonna.
Guys.
All I'm saying is that we might as well.
I'm saying We might as well What's the worst that could
happen You know Oh shit Okay guys We can continue What's the
worst that could happen Guys Like you We can't get worse
guys We can't We can't get worse possibly Right?
Guys What's the worst Surely This is it You have to lose
some to gain money, chat.
Like, it's not going to come in for free.
You have to take risks to get your money.
Oh, see, 9,000.
We can keep going.
I told you.
And then the next one will be, like, plus 20,000 after that.
Guys, actually, that would be, like, plus 20k.
Because what's the worst that could happen?
Like, I could lose more.
No, see, it's just 1,000 yen.
That's just $10.
Being, like, 500,000.
Like, yeah.
It's okay.
I'm good for my money.
You guys know that.
Okay, maybe I should stop.
Maybe I, I mean, 100k and down is up exactly, Kaz.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's okay.
The government will bail me out.
Look, Croesus.
At this level of debt, that isn't a red flag.
It's a back.
See, I told you 25,000 yen.
Guys, I'm almost out of debt.
guys guys i'm almost out of debt and don't worry the
government can bail me out i can i feel it i feel the
government bail out guys see look at don't worry if i go any
lower the government would be like oh my gosh here's here's
some free money we feel so so bad for you super shock thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you don't get the
type of person to twist it down thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you we can keep going guys we can keep going
the house is me i'm the house the house always wins that's
what they mean see it's okay it's okay i'm gonna win like
25k after this guys i'm gonna win 25k this is it one super
chat equals one gambling now thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you see look at that and then i'm money oh i
gotta i gotta raise guys i gotta raise there's a swimsuit
event oh my god no no you got you gotta cash out you're
gonna be in for too long yeah you gotta cash out you can't
you'll keep playing this forever you'll anyway guys we're
gonna call it here everybody as always everyone stay
hydrated we're gonna call had a great time everybody i hope
you guys had a great time with this stream if you guys want
to watch more of bunny garden don't worry everybody is
streaming it so you so if you want to learn more about
what's going on or you can play it yourself you can play it
yourself as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get
up and move around to get that blood flowing and if you head
to bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time
everybody bye guys bye